welcome to this video playing Matty 2000
from the UK during for the Sicilian for
change let's see the the closest Cillian
going to play with a quick go inside
expansion I think I'm played this before
and I got some trouble on the d5 pawn
but it should be three why why would you
play that running running right into
deform hmm
yeah okay I understand maybe that's not
really grateful black man but at least
it's a it's a it's an interesting
position 95 looks looks really weak it
seems he wants to put the night only 5
p.m. not only on f4 as I expected like
92 okay if I go here ok yeah this this I
thought should be quite ok still with
the idea to put a night only form I can
prepare it see 40m was hanging like 94
takes takes Knight see form not sure
about it but then it it was possible ok
i still have 94 here ok let's let's jump
right in
yeah with the weak spot on your form
black should be okay really would
surprise me if I'm them worse um f6 are
taking years from the useless ok let's
do f6 trying to get rid of the e5 Knight
it looks nice I mean this is a good
piece only form and it's not so clear
how White's play is going to be going to
be developed I think I probably would
have taken this as well the night is is
really an annoying piece and maybe you
can get an ID g3 now okay so how am I
going to play this just the bishop here
first maybe just improving it a bit also
making sure that d5 is never going to
happen maybe I get in FC 6f 5 i'm
getting this in hmm so this is good
though yeah
no but I have good control maybe I
should also make use of the B file on f5
I still can play g5 and keep things
under control I can also still go f5
it's not like I'm giving up on the IDM
with a 3 I have a maybe some spot on be
to the mat on the clock which is good
news not happening that often and i'm
not sure what King g2 was maybe it looks
like looks like a weird decision in any
case why is the King better than on g1
ok so let's let's put it down
yeah I'm still not really sure how to
continue I don't have rugby too but it's
of course an irritating thing in the
position frame but I cannot play it at
the moment
I'm wondering about at five still if I
should do that I don't think it's a
particularly good idea he's taking
really lots of time what I can also do
is try to do something with the sea porn
like Queen a 4c a4 a5 attacking the c3
porn and it's not moving here and since
the long nope seems like a connection
issue yeah that's unfortunate the
position is still very interesting I
don't really know if I have that much of
an advantage it's a it's it's nice of
course but how do you win it how do you
really break through now maybe I would
have gone for getting the Queen to h5
attacking c3 the queen is not doing that
much on d 7 yeah I don't know how long
it takes until the software here
recognizes the the distant like 40 feet
stinky this can actually know it it does
it's it's not clear to me how to
continue I think with the two bishops
and everything it should be okay for
white but it should be very okay for
black but I still don't know how to
continue if white is shuffling I mean
maybe I should really play at five huh
this is this i'm not sure i'm really not
sure that a five-point also is a target
for the night yeah maybe i need to do it
too to get get ahead but i was thinking
about this this kind of idea queen here
that's not bad white white really has a
hard time to do anything I can also
improve further but here yeah and then
go from there but it's not really clear
what I should do him while it's still
pretty solid I mean the computer is very
optimistic it gives minus one point
seven but I still don't see how to how
to directly break through him okay
thanks for watching